Santos has been accused of a lot of
things but he's he's not been convicted
of anything and he get that's crazy he's
guilty of being awesome the only two
people we ever thrown out before were
actually convicted of something so
that's a different standard but it's the
reason that it happened is because he is
because Republicans are stupid and
because Democrats are crafty Democrats
are more than happy to vote with Le and
I was there voting less than half the
Republicans voted for that interestingly
enough the new speaker of the house uh
Mike Johnson uh the majority leader
Steve scales the majority whip and the
everyone in leadership voted against
removing him against removing him as did
most Republicans but the Committee
reported it out nonetheless overriding
leadership wow yeah so I mean Kevin
McCarthy want to set up the committee he
he resigned now but the new speaker Mike
Johnson voted against it I don't know
how Kevin would have you know I don't
and so basically what was it how many
Republicans ended up voting it ended up
being like 111 voted no to expel them
including me and about 90 or so voted
yes to expel them so the minority of the
Republicans but every Democrat I think
one abstained but basically every
Democrat was more than happy to throw
him out